so i have a map here of united states
possessions in the pacific and in the
caribbean today
and they're kind of
all over the place i mean and some of
them are pretty tiny there's guam which
is just barely a little speck on the map
and
american samoa and
more well-known would be the hawaiian
islands right the one of the 50 states
of the united states
have you ever wondered
why the united states has islands in the
middle of the pacific i mean this is
thousands of miles from the mainland of
the united states so
what's the deal did the united states
just want access to somewhere to get a
tan and maybe buy some pineapple
in this video i want to talk about the
very unique historical circumstances
under which the united states acquired a
bunch of territory outside of the
borders of the lower 48 states
or how in other words the united states
became an empire
and
empire or
imperialism
is the practice of having
political or economic control
over a territory that is outside the
boundaries of your nation
so when did this happen and why did this
happen let me give you a little
background on the run-up to the united
states becoming an empire so the civil
war ends in 1865
and while that is a conflict just within
the united states right the definition
of civil war the civil war has kind of
an interesting effect on the united
states's economy because for the course
of the civil war the north
really ramped up their industrial
production to win the war so they build
railroad tracks and they have factories
that help them build the armaments that
are going to help them with victory in
the war well after the war all of these
factories all these railroads still
exist and they're turned to different
purposes so over the course of the late
19th century from the end of the civil
war really up until
you know even 1900 and beyond the united
states becomes the leading industrial
power in the world
so they make more stuff
than anybody else and this is one of the
reasons why so many immigrants are
flocking to the united states in this
time period because there are jobs and
factories but even though the u.s was
acknowledged as this great industrial
power it was not really acknowledged as
a world military power the number one
power in the world at this time is
england this is
the end of the victorian era
none of the nations of europe think of
the united states as
an important power in the world i mean
if you were a diplomat from france and
you got a diplomatic posting to
washington dc that would be like getting
a diplomatic posting on the moon there
is nothing going on there nobody is
interested you'd much rather be in
vienna or london but another reason why
the nations of europe are such important
world powers
is because of their own investment in
imperialism so let me show you a map of
the world in 1914 which is kind of after
this age of imperialism but it gives you
an idea of how much territory europe had
gobbled up in this time period
so this is the rest of the world in this
time period and we're talking about kind
of the period from about 1880
to 1900 and in this time period the
powers of europe
really competed with each other to
take over territories in the rest of the
world and these would have been
developing nations nations that did not
have the firepower to compete with
europe and they were generally nations
with a lot of natural resources
so in the mid-19th century there had
been explorers going throughout africa
this is the the period of dr livingston
i presume and dr livingston reports back
to england that there is a lot of stuff
in africa we're talking about diamonds
and
gold
and rubber and elsewhere in the world in
india there's tea and so in the 1880s
1890s europe scrambles for territorial
control of africa and you see
england here in south africa and france
up here in northwest africa and then of
course you've got england in india and
australia and you know they're even
fighting for influence in china and they
had two main reasons for wanting these
colonies abroad one is as we said
they're natural resources so they can
take all the raw materials the
unfinished goods
to
run the empire and then they can take
that back up to europe and process it so
it's a cheap source of stuff for their
industrial production
the other thing they want is markets
so all of these territories all of these
colonies have people in them who can buy
the products from the european nations
and as their factories produce more and
more stuff they need more and more
people to buy those things or they're
going to stagnate economically so this
is where the united states comes in so
in the late 19th century the us has
become this leading industrial power
they feel like they're not getting any
respect from europe for being pretty big
dogs but they also start looking at this
scramble for africa this scramble for
colonies in the world
and they think maybe the united states
should get in on this game and they have
a couple of reasons for doing this one
of the reasons for doing this is the
idea of expanding the frontier
so in the late 19th century
there was a
pretty famous historian by the name of
frederick jackson turner
and what turner has to say really
troubles a lot of people he says
manifest destiny
is done
so manifest destiny you'll recall is
this idea that god wanted the united
states to occupy the north american
continent from atlantic to pacific as of
1890 the census showed that there was
pretty much even population distribution
all the way to the pacific ocean so this
process of conquering the frontier that
many white americans thought was really
crucial to the american spirit was over
so what is the united states going to do
culturally they pride themselves on
being a pioneering people but along with
that goes the same sort of quest for new
markets that europe is going through in
the same time period
so
if the united states is the world's
leading industrial power
and they did that by conquering the
frontier building railroads finding new
people to sell the products of their
factory to what's going to happen if
they have nowhere else to expand
relentless expansion is kind of the
backbone of american capitalism and so
people started to worry that if
expansion is done then the american
industrial project is going to falter
with no new markets to conquer
all right so those are the economic and
cultural explanations for why the united
states became
interested in being an imperial power at
the end of the 19th century there are
also some military explanations so let
me take you back to a map of the pacific
so in 1890 this man named alfred thayer
mahan
published a book
called the influence
of sea power upon history
and mahan's thesis was that all the
great
nations of history since time immemorial
had gotten their greatness through a
domination of the seas
so he says
that if the united states really wants
to be a world power going forward
they're going to have to make some
serious investments in their navy
he says first they're going to have to
build a really powerful naval fleet
which has never really been the bread
and butter of america's military i mean
up until this point the united states
navy was like five leaky boats so he
says they have to build a powerful navy
and that you should consider
putting a canal
somewhere across central america so that
if a ship is in the atlantic it doesn't
have to go all the way around south
america to get to the pacific it can
just cut this corner here
and the last thing that mahan says is
that the u.s is going to need friendly
ports all over the world so that this
navy can dock places refuel take on new
supplies because if your ports are only
on the edges of the united states it
could take you days and days and days to
make it all the way over to asia
so mahan says we need good harbors along
the way and you know what's a really
great harbor
pearl harbor in hawaii it's one of the
best harbors in the world
and basically in the future the us
government is going to do exactly what
mohan says
in between 1890 and 1914 the united
states increases their investment in the
navy by a power of seven it's 22 million
dollars only in 1890 by 1914 they're
putting 140 million dollars a year into
their navy
and they will move forward with this
plan to build a canal somewhere in
central america hint hint it might be in
panama
and they will annex ports
all over the pacific
and also in the caribbean
to take care of their new powerful navy
so in the late 19th century the us is
really poised to enter into world
politics as a major world power in the
next video i'll talk about the
spanish-american war of 1898 and how
that led the united states to become an
empire